J'ai 29 frères et sœurs ma mère est mon monde
mais mon père ne les autorise pas à
me parler parce que je suis un apostat
[Musique]
si vous êtes surpris en train de parler à la
voisine ou si vous l'êtes, je veux dire si
vous avez été surpris en train de le regarder trop
longtemps, alors vous avez des problèmes,
dites que je reçois un appel d'elle, mon père reçoit un
appel de Warren  Jess c'est qu'il est le seul à
pouvoir se marier est là
je vais à son bureau et cette fille au hasard
franchit la porte je ne lui ai jamais
parlé je l'avais vu de loin
j'entre et je me marie avec ça  fille
et à partir de là, comment nous devons comprendre la
vie Je ne voulais pas ce style
de vie pour moi
et donc je suis sorti à 17 ans Je
ne pouvais pas vraiment dire au revoir à qui que ce soit ou à des
choses comme ça parce que si je le savais, je savais que
je savais  Je ne pourrais pas sortir
avec ma famille
[Musique]
depuis que j'ai quitté le FLDS, ça fait, je veux dire,
ça fait un peu  ma bouée de sauvetage
[Musique]
les coupes de cheveux dans le FLDS où j'ai grandi
Je veux dire que le style que j'ai maintenant
n'est pas autorisé
[Musique]
ils se laissent pousser les cheveux la plupart de leur
vie, puis ils les tressent et ils les
mettent  au sommet de leur tête et c'est un
peu leur culture, donc une grande
importance pour eux, c'est quand ils
arrivent et que nous nous coupons les cheveux, cela
commence vraiment le nouveau chemin parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
regarder en arrière après ça
[Music]
c'est presque une libération de style  pour
eux et cela leur donne un nouveau
souffle si vous remarquez qu'avec Howard, je veux dire
une fois qu'il s'est fait couper les cheveux, il a commencé à
s'ouvrir d'une manière complètement différente pour
obtenir ma première coupe de cheveux après avoir quitté
le FLDS, je veux dire que ça m'a fait me sentir  comme
si c'était quelqu'un de différent.